The second law of thermodynamics
states that the entropy, or disorder,
of a closed system is always increasing.
One way of thinking about entropy
is a measure of disorder or chaos in the universe.
The more entropy we generate, the less
energy is left over to do useful work.
If you think about entropy statistically,
you could think about it in terms of a puzzle
where you have to figure out
how many combinations there are
of putting three balls into three boxes.
Well, there's 10.
In three cases you'll have
three balls in one of the boxes.
There's one where
there's a ball in every box.
And the other six will have them
all spread out to a different degree.
That's straightforward enough
but when you scale it up,
even by a factor of 10,
things get much more complicated.
Counting the permutations
becomes impossible.
Now if you imagine that there
were trillions upon trillions of atoms
and trillions upon trillions of boxes,
then statistically you could see
that it's much more likely that the atoms
would be disordered rather than ordered.
Perhaps the most significant conclusion
from the second law of thermodynamics
is the concept of the arrow of time which
tells you which direction time is travelling
in.
For example if a process generates entropy,
it will happen spontaneously
and will be irreversible
unless you input more energy.
When I pour cream on my coffee,
I wouldn't be surprised to see
the two liquids mixing and becoming
more disordered over time.
I would, however be surprised
if the cream and coffee separated again
after I had stirred them.
An ice cube in coffee will melt
and become a more disordered liquid.
But under those conditions it
cannot spontaneously reform itself
back into an ice cube.
You might be tempted to think
that if this is true
and if entropy can never be decreased,
then how can human beings or more
complex living organisms even exist?
Well, the key here is that
humans are not a closed system.
We are always exchanging heat
with our surroundings
and we're decreasing local entropy at the
expense of the entropy of our environments.
So if I take an egg and I drop it,
then the second law says that this egg
will never spontaneously unbreak itself.
But even the initial laying of the
egg doesn't violate the second law,
because the hen took a lot
of food and broke it down,
so creating a lot of molecular
disorder or entropy,
in order to make this egg
that I've just broken.
The second law states that a
spontaneous process generates entropy
and involves heat moving
from a hotter body to a colder body.
Now a refrigerator doesn't violate
the second law of thermodynamics
because it's not a
closed, isolated system.
We're continually inputting energy
in the form of electricity
to try and keep the inside
of the refrigerator cold
but at the expense of
the surrounding environment.
If we turned off the electricity then
eventually the air inside the refrigerator
would come into thermal equilibrium
with the surrounding environment.
The concept of thermal equilibration
leads to the idea of the universe's heat death.
Now this is an idea where heat flowing
from a hotter body to a colder body
will eventually lead to a situation
where all of the atoms in the universe
are at thermal equilibrium and there won't
be any drivers for spontaneous processes
and things will just stop.
But the good news is that this isn't
going to happen for a very long time.
It's been predicted to happen in
10 to the power of 26 years.
That's 10 with 26 zeroes behind it.
So we can take comfort in the fact
that we can continue to create things
and draw local order from the chaos
for a long time to come.